[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
يا عم السعر
وامجد
يا بلد والله السعوديه تتصدر مجموعتها في
كاس العالم بانتصار تاريخي على الارجنتين
رفاق عويس افضل من رفاق ميسي
باستعراض كامل جيشه
روسيا الرسميه تقول انها منفتحه على
المفاوضات وروسيا غير الرسميه تعتبرها
فرصه لالتقاط الانفاس قبل معركه اكبر
تابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
تويتر يهاجم الموظفين المفصولين بعد رفعهم
دعوى قضائيه ويقرر تجنيد مستحقاتهم حتى
اشعار اخر
سلطه العمليه العسكريه التركيه الضوء من
جديد على الوضع المعقد شمال سوريا كانت
عمليه جويه ويبدو انها ستتحول قريبا
لعمليه رابعه منذ عام 2016 الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان اعلنها صراحه اليوم بعدما
كانت تلميحات بالامس قائلا ان بلاده ستشن
قريبا عمليه بريه في سوريا ضد المقاتلين
الاكراد اردوغان صرح في خطاب المسلسل بان
طائرات ومدافع ومسيرات بلاده حلقت فوق من
اسمائهم بالارهابيين لبضعه ايام مضيفا
سنقتعهم جميعا قريبا بالدبابات بالمدفعيه
والجنود
[موسيقى]
حلقنا فوق الارهابيين لبضعه ايام
بطائراتنا ومدافعنا ومسيراتنا سنقتلعهم
جميعا قريبا بالدبابات والمدفعيه والجنود
اعلم هذا
تصريحات الرئيس التركي اضاف عليها وزير
الداخليه
بالقول ان تركيا ان لم تسمح باقامه ما
وصفها بدوله ارهابيه عند حدودها سويل قال
انه يجب على تركيا
ومواطنها وهذا حق المشروع لكل دوله هذا ما
تستمر القوته التركيه بعمله اذن على ما
يبدو بانتظار العمليه البريه المرصد
السوري افادى اليوم بمقتل عنصرين من قوات
سوريا ديمقراطيه قصد
ومع اصابته الثلاثه بقصفا لمسير تركيا على
قاعده عسكريه في الحسكه
[موسيقى]
التحركات التركيه والتصعيد والتهديد
بالعمليه البريه الرابعه اعرب الكلام
ازاءها عن تفاهمه واحترامه لمخاوف انقره
الامنيه لكنه في الوقت نفسه دعى الاطراف
كافه الى تجنب الخطوات التي قد تؤدي الى
تدهور الوضع الامني وحذر انقراما ان اي
مبادره يمكن ان تؤدي الى زعزعه خطيره
للوضع العام في سوريا
[موسيقى]
نفهم مخاوف تركيا المرتبطه بامنها لكن في
الوقت عينه ندعو جميع الاطراف الى
الامتناع عن اي مبادره يمكن ان تؤدي الى
زعزعه خطيره للوضع العام
اللاعب الرئيس الاخر شمال سوريا الولايات
المتحده عبر متحدثا باسم وزاره خارجيتها
عبر عن معارضه واشنطن لاي تحرك عسكري
يزعزع واستقرار الوضع في سوريا واضاف بانه
واشنطن ابلغت انقره بقلقها البالغ من
تاثير التصعيد على هدف محاربه تنظيم داعش
فيما تسعى قصد الى وقت التصعيد التركيه
ضدها عبر التواصل مع واشنطنوسكو بحسب
قائدها العام مظلوم عبدي مع انه يرى ان
الموقف الامريكي موقف النظام السوري من
مقتل عناصر بالغارات التركيه ضعيف للغايه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللافت ان السماء السوريه تزخر او تزدحم
بالطائرات غارات متزامنه باهداف مختلفه
بداتها اسرائيل وتابعتها تركيا وختمتها
روسيا الى الان على الاقل كانت الايام
القليله الماضيه مرهقه اكثر من اي وقت مضى
بالنسبه لمراقبه الطائرات كانت مرهقه لهم
عبرت القوات الجويه
لثلاث دول سماء سوريا عبرت عن قوتها هناك
عندما عبرت في تلك السماء وقصفت اهدافا في
ساحل المتوسط منه الى صحار الشرق سنه كل
من تركيا واسرائيل وروسيا غارات في الايام
الاخيره مؤكده من جديد ان الحرب المستمره
منذ عقد من الزمن لا تزال صراعا مفتوحا مع
امكانيه التصعيد على الثلاث جبهات على
الاقل
[موسيقى]
بدا وقبل القذف في ساعه المبكره من صباح
السبت عندما استهدفت غارات اسرائيليه
وفي قلب البلاد تحديدا مدن اللاذقيه وحما
وحمس اسفره الغارات عن مقتل اربعه من
عناصر النظام السوريه في احدث سلسله من
الضربات ضد اهداف تابعه لمليشيات حزب الله
اللبناني الموالي الايراني
كرديه في شمال شرق سوريا قبل ان يطلق
الرئيس
من الذي بقي بقيت روسيا التي شاركت صباح
الاثنين بقصف استهدف مناطق ريفيه في
محافظه ادلب بالقرب من الحدود التركيه
ومواقع مدنيه بالقرب من مخيمين للاجئين
تنقل صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه عن نازح
سوري في ادلب قوله ان الجميع يتحكمون في
سماءنا مشبها غارات اسرائيل وتركيا وروسيا
بانها مثل الصقور التي تلتقط الارانب
صحيفه نقلت عن الدكتوره لينا الخطيب وهي
مديره برنامج الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
في مركز الابحاث قولها ان الحرب في سوريا
تخاطر بان تصبح صراعا منسيا لكن الضربات
الجويه المستمره من قبل تركيا وروسيا
واسرائيل تظهر ان المصالح الاقليميه لا
تزال فع
تستهدف كل دوله من الدول الثلاث خصومها
لمنعهم من تعزيز نفوذهم في سوريا
يمثل هذا تفكيرا بان الصراع السوري ليس
صراعا منعزلا ولا حربا اهليه اذ لطالما
لعبت المصالح الاقليميه والدوليه الدوله
الاكبر وتهدف الغارات التركيه والروسيه
والاسرائيليه المتكرره الى حمايه تلك
المصالح
[موسيقى]
معنى من باريس المحلل والخبير العسكري عبد
الناصر العايد اهلا بك معنا سيد عبد
الناصر واسالك اولا عن قراءتك لكل ما
اسلفناه لتو بشان تحكم هذه الدول الثلاثه
على الاقل في السماء تلك المناطق كل يعزز
نفوذه ويحاول ان يحد من نفوذ الطرف الاخر
وهذا الواقع المستمر منذ سنوات وليس الان
فقط ولكن يبدو انه عاد المشهد الى التصعيد
من جديد
امطار مساء الخير مساء يعني الحاله
السوريه حاله مدونه بامتياز
سياسيه وعسكريا وبشريا حتى يعني اللاجئين
السوريين الان نتيجه هذه الحرب بيملؤون
اسقع الدنيا
ليست ثلاثه اطراف فقط في السماء السوريه
وعلى الارض السوريه يعني جبل لا ننسى
الطيران الامريكي موجود ليل نهار يعني
وعندما يحتاج لتنفيذ اي عمليه يعني قواعده
موجوده في سوريا وعندما يحتاج الى اي
عمليه تطير طائرته اليسر وتقصف وايضا
ايران موجوده بالطائراتها المسيره في كل
مكان تقريبا على وطن عن ميليشاتها
المنتشره على المجمل الارض السوريه يعني
همم هناك همم توليفه من القوه الدوليه
الكبرى من روسيا وامريكا واصولا الى القوه
الاقليميه المهمه تركيه ايران اسرائيل همم
ايضا الدول اخرى غربيه مثل فرنسا
وبريطانيا ايضا لديها ومصالح اا عسكريه في
سوريا
فالمشهد السوري مدول يعني بشكل كبير اا
هذا واقع يعني لم يتم تغيره منذ فتره
طويله باكستاني هل يمكن ادخال بعض
الاقتراحات او المبادرات التي يمكن على
الاقل ان تحد من عمليه عسكريه بريه تركيه
في الشمال السوري مع تهديدات الاخيره
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يعني الحل بشكل عام هو بيد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل قاطع ونهائي هي
والدول الغربيه همم
بالدرجه الثانيه بيدرسها بالنسبه للحل
بهذه الجزئيه يعني ايضا المفتاح بيد
الولايات المتحده ويعتقد على نطاق واسع
انها سمحت بالعمليه الجويه التركيه واسعه
النطاق الحاليه همم غير المسبوقه يعني في
عمقها وعنفها وشدتها اليوم تم تصف لاول
مره يعني طيران تركي لاول مره يمكن في
التاريخ حتى يقصف الطيران تركي في محافظه
دير الزور اللي هي ليست محافظه حدوديه مع
مع الاتراك لكن ايضا المعلومات المتوفره
حتى الان تقول انه ما في ضوء اخضر امريكي
رامي على اتخاذ مواقف سياسيه معينه همم
مشفوعه بهذا القصف يعني العنيف لكن عمليه
بريه حتى الان همم المعلومات يعني
المعلومات الخاصه التي تتوفر لدينا تقول
انه ما في تحضيرات على الاقل او تجهيز
لمعركه بريه بس ما خياطه
من المفترض انها همم تتلقى الدعم من
الولايات المتحده في احيان كثيره همم وتصف
مواقف الولايات المتحده الان
بالمتردده وان تتحدث عن الضوء الاخضر
الامريكي
لتركيا لقصف هذه المواقع بالتالي همم باي
خيارات همم يملك المقاتلون الاكراد وهم
بين مطرقه وسندام
يعني الحقيقه موقفهم صعب وهذا موقف يعني
موقف مصعب بنزل البدايه هم يعني ااا في في
حاله جيبه لتيكيه
صعبه الحل اذا لم تكن مستحيله شانهم شان
كل القضيه السوريه بصراحه همم الان هم همم
يعني يبدو انهم مطالبون باتخاذ
بالتقديم تنازلات واضحه ومحدده بخصوص كون
الكيان الذي يعني يرينه وهو كيان كردي
يوحي بانفصال ماء همم هذا لا يرضي لا
تركيا ولا ايران ولا يعني وليس يعني احد
الاهداف الامريكيه من دعممهم هم دعمهم
باتجاه قضيه محاربه الارهاب محاربه داعش
همم يبدو انه هناك ضغط باتجاه حل هذا
الكيان بصيغه مع الالقاء على بعض
المكتسبات وال الغريب انه الحل هذا يعني
لا يمكن ان يتم الا من خلال تسليمهم بهذه
المرحله يعني تسليم مناطقهم او تسليم
اداره مناطقهم للنظام
هو هو الجهه الوحيده التي يمكن لتركيا ان
تقبل بانه ينحل فيها هذا الكيان اللي اسمه
همم قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اللي هي
بتصرفه التركيه اتصفه بانه كيان تابع لحزب
العمال الكردستاني لا تعترف بكل المسميات
ولا ادعاءات خاصه الامريكان يبدو انهم
متناهين مع الاتراك الى درجه ما بهذا
التصور همم وانه هم دائما المسؤولين
الامريكان بيرددوا له عباره انه نحن ما
جينا ندعم القوات الكرديه لا تساوي دوله
نحن جينا ندعمناهم بمعركه محدده ووضحت
الاهداف ووضح السياق هي محاربه تنظيم داعش
لذلك اليوم
استاذ عبد الناصر
وانا استغليت الموضوع لانهي المقابله لانه
انتهى وقتنا ههه شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عبد
الناصر العايد الخبير والمحلل العسكري من
باريس تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
تقرير لنيوزويك يكشف احد اوجه الاستفاده
الامريكيه من الحرب في اوكرانيا التخلص من
روسيا دون ارسال جنود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
الازمه الاوكرانيه والمفاوضات لحلها ملف
مازال مفتوحا مع رفض الطرفين الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات حاليا الرئيس
سبتمبر الماضي انه مستعدو للحوار مع روسيا
لكن مع رئيس اخر غير فلاديمير بوتن وفي
اليوم التالي اصدر مرسوما رئاسيا باستحاله
اجراء محادثات
ان موسكو اما ستنتظر ان يغيرنسكي موقفه او
ان يغير الرئيس الاوكراني المقبل
لصالح شعبه الطرفان متباعدان في هذا الصدد
وافاق تسويه تبدو بعيده الا ان المؤشرات
تدل على وجود رغبات دوليه في ان يعود
الطرفان للتفاوض بلوره رؤيه للحل
واشنطن بدورها قالت على لسان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي جون كوربي ان الامر
متروك للرئيس جنسكي ليقرر ما اذا كان
مستعدا ام لا ومتى سيكون مستعدا للتفاوض
وما هو الشكل الذي سيتخذه هذا التفاوض
الموقف الامريكي يظهر دعما للتفاوض الا ان
الرئيس الروسي قال ان واشنطن تدير
دبلوماسيه كياف كما يدير تنتجون المعارك
من الجانب الاوكراني على حد قوله بوتن
من ناحيه تظهر الولايات المتحده دعما
للمسار الدبلوماسي بينما تدفع بمساعدات
لاوكرانيا لتحقيق غايات لدى الاداره
الامريكيه مجله نيوز ويك تناولت هذا
الموضوع تحديدا وقالت ان المساعدات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا استثمار كبير
للولايات المتحده التي تنفق مبالغه قليلا
نسبيا للوصول الى مكاسبه اكبر خاصه اذا
هزمت روسيا منذ بدايه الحرب
13 مليارا و600 مليون دولار كمساعدات
للاوكرانيين وفي مايو وافق مجلس الشيوخ
على ما يقرب من اربعين مليار دولار كدعم
الاضافي يشمل النواحي العسكريه
والاقتصاديه والانسانيه وفي منتصف الشهر
الجاري طلب البيت الابيض من الكونجرس
الموافقه على 88 مليار دولار اخرى من
المساعدات العسكريه والانسانيه لا
قالت ان المساعدات تمثل 5:30 من اجمالي
الانفاق الدفاعي الامريكي وتوفر فرصه
للولايات المتحده لتقويض القدره دفاعيه
التقليديه لروسيا دون ارسال جندي واحد الى
ارض المعركه لمواجهه التهديد الروسي كما
نقلت نيوزويك عن محللين قولهم ان حجم
الاموال التي تنفقها الولايات المتحده على
اوكرانيا لا شيء لا شيء مقارنه بما تحصل
عليه واشنطن في المقابل سواء على ارض
المعركه بخساره روسيا او بحدوث تغييرات في
الداخل الروسي
[موسيقى]
في مصر
قال على شاشه التلفزيون رسمي ان المفاوضات
الروسيه مع اوكرانيا حيله لتاخير الحرب
حتى تستعيد روسيا قوتها للهجوم ومواصله
القتال ياتي حديث السياسي الروسي
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا ان روسيا منفتحه
على محادثات السلام ومستعد للتفاوض
فلبين قال ان مواطنيه سعداء بالضربات
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الا ان الضربات لن
تهزمك اف لكنها قد تدفعها لطاوله
المفاوضات كما اعتبر ان روسيا تريد
التفاوض كغاء لاعاده جمع قواتها وانهاء
القتال في وقت لاحق على الرغم من اي
اتفاقات سلام محتمله اعتبر السياسي الروسي
ان اتفاقات منسك بدات نتيجه انتصارات
عسكريه حاسمه لروسيا وانه اذا كان الجانب
الروسي يريد المفاوضات حقا فانه لن يحتاج
ايضا الى تعزيز مصر العسكري وانهاء الحرب
على ساحه المعركه وليس بالتفاوض لن يحتاج
الا لتعذيذه وضعه العسكري
[موسيقى]
استحواذ ايلون ماسك على تويتر ومتاعب
الموقع الازرق في تصاعد اخرها امام القضاء
في سامسونج
اي حوالي نصف القوه العامله للشركه وقالوا
انهم لم يحصلوا على انذار قبل ان يتم
فصلهم قام تويتر فتقولوا ان ذلك لم يحدث
اشعارا مدته 60 يوما قبل التسريح الجماعيه
وحذرت شركه من تاخر صرف مستحقات الموظفين
المفصولين طالما استمرت هذه الدعوه امام
القضاء
[موسيقى]
الحديث عن انهيار تويتر يبدو اخطر مما هو
متصور فالموقع يساعد على مواجهه الكوارث
الطبيعيه
قبل ان تجتاح الرياح الموسميه اندونيسيا
هذا العام قام 25 مليون شخص في جميع انحاء
البلاد بتحميل صور ذات علامات جغرافيه على
الموقع من اجل المساعده مع وصول الفيضانات
وفي الهند ساعد الموقع السكان في الوصول
الى مواقع لقاحات كورونا وفي امريكا ساعد
في التحذير من مواقع اطلاق النار الجماعيه
يقول موظفون سابقون في تويتر ان هذا
التواصل الذي يوفره الموقع قد يكون في خطر
مع فصل الموظفين التقنيين من الشركه فقد
تتاخر الخدمه او تتعطل حتى يوجد على تويتر
وقد اثبت انه اداه قيمه للحد من مخاطر
الكوارث ولادارتها كما اظهرت ابحاثه
المتعدده ولكن حينما تاتي الكارثه المقبله
قد يتوقف الموقف كله عن العمل مع الضغط
شديد على الموقع دون وجود تقنيين لمواجهه
هذا الضغط وبالفعل ابلغ مستخدمون في مناطق
مختلفه في العالم عن بطء الموقع في امريكا
الهند اندونيسيا الشرق الاوسط هذا البطء
قد يعني الحياه او الموت في حالات الطوارئ
تقول الباحث في جامعه ماريلاند كارولين
اور سواء كان تويتر اداه تواصل للافضل او
للاسواء فلا توجد اداه حاسمه في حالات
الكوارث
من امام مقر تويتر
اهلا بك معنا حسين كيف تغير او اختلف
المشهد بين رسالتك امس من امام مبنى تويتر
في سامسونج
تحيه لك طاهر الجديد هو ما نقلته صحف
امريكيه عن موظفين عقدوا اجتماعا البارحه
مع الماسك الذي قال لهم ان مرحله الاقلات
قد انتهت الان والان هناك مرحله جديده هي
مرحله التوظيف ولاسيما في قسمي الهندسه
والمبيعات البارحه كانت اخر موجه من
الانقلاب في قصه في قسم المبيعات لم يحدد
العدد الذي اقيل ولكن كان هناك اقلاء لهم
ماسك يحث الموظفين الباقين داخل هذا
المبنى الذي يظهر خلفي يحثه على تزكيه
اشخاص يرونهم مناسبين لكي يعملوا معه في
قسم الهندسه التركيز على الهندسه كبير لدى
ايرون ماسك لم يستبعد عن يبدا من السفر في
بعض اقسام الهندسه وايضا لم يستبعد ان
يعتمد على اكثر من فريق حول العالم في
الهند في اندونيسيا في البرازيل وهمم وفي
همم في اماكن اخرى في الولايات المتحده
لكي يقوموا بالصيانه الموقع الذي حسب ما
قرانا ايضا بدا يواجه مشاكل تقنيه فعلى
سبيل المثال المستخدمون تحدث همم خلال
نهايه الاسبوع عن تعطل في نظام حمايه حقوق
النشر التلقائي لم يعد يعمل بالكامل خلال
نهايه الاسبوع ما سمح لعدد من المستخدمين
مستخدمين تويتر بان يرفع مثلا افلاما
كامله مثل همم افاتار على هذا الموقع طبعا
هم قاموا بتقسيمه الى دقائق دقيقتين لان
نظام تويتر لا يسمح بان ترفع اكثر من
دقيقه من الفيديو
ما كان هذا انت هذا الحقوق النشر همم هنا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واشاره حسب
خبراء الى همم ضعف هشاشه النظام حاليا
بسبب النقص في التقنيين وفي المهندسين
الذين اما اقيلوا واما استقاله ما دفع الى
الماسك همم طاهر يعني يدعوا على من استقال
منهم الى العوده وايضا طلب من ايه مهندسين
في شركه تسلا ان ياتوا الى هذا الموقع هنا
في سان فرانسيسكو لكي يساعد على صيانه
موقع تويتر وتقديم الدعم لزملائهم تمام
همم وايلون ماسك يبدو انه همم يعني همم
تعب فعلا بعد تغريدتهم منذ 11 ساعه عم اذا
كان التغريد ايضا يعد عملا وبانتظار ان
يعود الى التغريد هذه الليله اريد ان
اسالك عن تفصيل اكثر انت توفر في النقطه
الاخيره التي ذكرتها قبل قليل عن كيفيه
تعويض من قام باقالتهم من تقنيين وعن همم
اذا كان هناك خطه واضحه همم يقولها ماسك
او المدافعون همم عن سياساته فيما يتعلق
بمواجهه مخاطر التعطل التقنيه
بحسب ااا ما نقلت مساء العلامه امريكيه ان
لهم مسكن لديه خطه مسبقه قبل ان يشترطبه
وعندما اشتريت تويتر هو طلب من مبرمجين في
شركاته الاخرى مثل تسلا بان ياتوا الى
المركز الرئيسي ويجتمع بالموظفين التقنيين
هنا في سان فرانسيسكو وتم اختار هؤلاء
الموظفين قبل نصف ساعه تقريبا من الاجتماع
رموز الشفره او رموز القوه اللي هي
البرمجه السوفت ويرز ل- يحضروها معهم الى
الاجتماع هذا ما فعلوه وقدمه لهم الخبراء
يقولون ان هؤلاء الذين اتى بهم من شركات
اخرى اطلعوا على كيفيه عمل نظام همم تويتر
واصبحوا قادرين على ان على الاقل ان يمتص
وسط الاولى الان كيف سيتم التعويض باب همم
باب التوظيف سيفتح حسب ما اعلن هو طبعا
على الموقع لا يوجد اي اشاره الى وظائف
شاغره الان ولكن همم
بالمناسبه انا هنا كنت موجود امام همم باب
الشركه والتقيت بشاب سالته هل انت موظف في
تويتر قال لي لا انا همم اتيت الى الشركه
بحثا عن الوظيفه فسالته ما ماذا حدث معك
قال عندما وصلت الى باب الشركه وقلت
لموظفين استقبال بانني ابحث عن وظيفه
فتويتر استقبال استقبلوه وسامحوا له
بالصعود الى همم الطوابق العليا في الشركه
اللي يقي لكي يقدم في سيرته الذاتيه قلت
له يعني همم هل ساعدوه قال لي كانوا
يساعدوني بشكل كبير جدا هم يريدون الان
موظفين وهذا معنى انه ماسك هو يريد موظفين
خاصه في خصم الهندسه لكي يعوض همم نتوقع
قريبا من طاهر ان يتم فتح باب التنظيف في
شركه حسن همم تذكر وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه بسبب هذا المحصل الذي حصل نحن
نتحدث عن موقع ضخم جدا همم يعني الخبره
يقولون لا يمكن بالعدد القليل من التقنيين
ان يحافظوا على صيانته وان يحموه من اهل
الهجمات السيبرنيه والالكترونيه
لذلك هو سيعود النقص بعض الاراء تقول بان
عدد من الذين استقالوا او من الذين اقيلوا
هو في الحقيقه لم يكن يعمل بشكل فعال لهذا
السبب قام الى الماسك بترده ولكن هناك
اخرى تقول بانه تسرع بذلك كان يعتقد بانه
يستطيع ان يسيطر على الموضوع ولكن الامور
فلتت من يديه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات من امام مقر تويتر في سان
فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه حسين التوت
تحياتي اليك في العربيه 360 ايضا بينما
تتقرب من الصين المانيا تقول انها لا تخشى
من عالم متعدد الاقطار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
على ضروره تحسين الاتصالات بين الصين
وامريكا اثناء الازمات وذلك خلال اجتماع
مع نظيره الصينيه
الدفاع الامريكي قلقه بشان ما اعتبره
سلوكا خطيرا للطائرات العسكريه الصينيه
فوق تايوان واكدت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ان الاجتماع استمر 90 دقيقه وكان مثمرا
ومهنيا وهو اول اجتماع من نوعه زياره
رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكيه نانسي
ذلك الاجتماع وبتزامن معه وزاره نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كمالاهارس جزيره بالاوان
الفلبينيه التي تعتبرها الصين جزءا من
اراضيها في بحر السنين الجنوبي وقالت حارس
انه يجب دفاعه عن احترام السياده ووحده
الاراضي وحريه الملاحه والتحليق في بحر
الصين الجنوبي
غير القانوني وغير المسئوله
في كل مكان يجب ان نتمسك بالقواعد
والمعايير الدوليه يجب ان ندافع عن مبادئ
مثل احترام السياده ووحده الاراضي
والتجاره المشروعه دون عوائق
النزاعاته وحريه الملاحه والتحليق في بحر
السنه الجنوبيه